so knowing that there's a shredder that
shreds
people's egos and all this stuff and it
can do a lot of damage
you still remained you still seem
humble and in good spirits i'm sure
there's days that it's maybe
tougher than others yesterday okay okay
maybe then i'm wrong all right
so all right but then how do you remain
level or maybe you just accept that
that's not there's an ebb and flow
you're going to have a dark day you're
going to have a good day you're going to
have a
sad you know i want to quit
um how do you maintain your
self uh ness
i was very very fortunate 40 years ago
to discover transcendental meditation
gentile meditation saves my life every
single day i meditate every day
and i do things like yoga
i am a crazy person so i do beak from
yoga
112 degrees and 26 postures
and that takes a lot of stress out and a
little tai chi
i'm in the gym three days a week
so it builds my it's not only my
physical
but it builds my my fortitude and i
believe in god
i see the witness i mean
i'm not i don't go to church very much
but
i i i know from
the experiencing there's something there
i i i can't describe it to you
i've seen divine intervention i i i it's
i can tell you i'll give you one example
of the show that's going to probably get
done this movie i was sitting in a
restaurant talking
about this organization that i really
needed to
come on board to make this movie happen
me and my friend were talking
me my lawyer were talking and how are we
going to get to this
organization i don't really know anybody
in the organ in you know the studio and
organization et cetera
and so there's this guy sitting with two
people
next to us and every once in a while he
look over at us you know
so he gets me pays the bill and um
he says here's my card
he was the guy
he he was the executive at the studio
what are the take that what are the
chances
you